all right having some fun and spooky
season cuz I love Star Trek the Next
Generation you know I love Star Trek the
Next Generation so this is the perfect
time for me to list off my top five
creepiest or otherwise scariest episodes
of Star Trek the Next Generation but
first
ponsor I do have a fun sponsorship for
you today this video is brought to you
by Paradox talking about the game Star
Trek infinite that's right cuz what's
better than Trek more Trek Star Trek
infinite a strategy game you can play as
the Federation Klingon Empire Romulan
Empire or Kardashian Union chart explore
oniz planets expand your borders create
faction between you and the other
civilizations it very much is like the
game civilization and Star Trek went
Splat I love both so you put them
together that's a perfect sponsorship
for me you don't have to play Within the
box of what you think you should play as
when you play as one faction or another
you can be a warmongering federation
leader you can be a peacekeeping
Kardashian leader who takes there are
four lights as an acceptable answer and
I did get a notification that a vessel
was attacked by a structure at Wolf 359
it could be every bit as horrifically
sweat inducing as it sounds I don't know
I haven't gone there yet I will after
this video but if you're looking for a
fun immersive Trek Experience that we'll
have you saying just one more turn until
about 4:00 a.m. click the link below and
lose yourself for hours all right
getting to the list a couple things to
know this isn't a top five well it is
it's a top five but they're not in order
of preferred to least preferred or vice
versa they're not in any real order of
preference I put them in order of you
know it's kind of like making a mixtape
or a playlist if you prefer did I just
age myself with the term mixtape
whatever get your Walkman boom box or
otherwise tape player together and let's
go down this Rabbit Hole of the top five
scariest Star Trek the Next Generation
episodes for me starting out this list
season 4 episode 17 the episode known as
night terrors the crew the Enterprise
runs across this ghost ship and it looks
like the crew just went mad then they
themselves start getting agitated
irritable they start hallucinating
seeing things hearing things that aren't
there this is the episode that actually
taught me the importance of sleep and
dreaming and how if you don't don't do
that you'll just go nuts counselor Troy
floating through green screen dream
sequences aside this episode has some
pretty solid psychological horror
moments this is a great episode showing
a crew's descent into Insanity due to a
lack of what we all require every night
sleep and dreams which makes it
relatable effective and scary next up we
have season 4 episode 18 identity crisis
that was a one two punch episodes 17 and
18 both on this list didn't know it when
I picked them but when I picked them and
it all started to come into Focus two
back-to-back episodes of Trek in my
formative years that led to probably
more therapy than I otherwise would have
required now identity crisis I've
actually mentioned in other videos Jordi
leforge is changing into another life
form that would be creepy enough but
it's not what creeps me out with this
episode the real creep Factor comes from
Jordy looking over old footage of a
mission he was on he notices a shadow
that doesn't belong to anyone in the
frame he goes to the Hol deck he has the
computer just eliminate the people and
lo and behold there's this Rogue Shadow
he says all right computer if the shadow
belongs to someone of my height and
general Dimensions where would this
person or thing be the computer just
plops it right in front of him there was
just someone there amidst everybody and
no one knew it because the being was
invisible that haunted me as a child
continues to haunt me to this day the
concept of someone being there without
you knowing just scares the living
out of me I don't like the feeling I
mean I kind of like it but I don't like
it I love to be scared by it and that
that attachment comes from this episode
any shape seen in the shadows anytime
you've looked into the woods while
camping and feel like you're being
watched to me it's this episode even
Blair Witch Project threw me back to
this episode of Trek it's the concept of
a ghost watching you in your house
without you knowing but something more
tangible in the physical world because
it's a humanoid life form holding to the
tradition of bone chilling holc reveals
we have season 6 episode five the
episode schisms this is another episode
where the crew of the Enterprise is like
I'm not getting a lot of sleep I'm kind
of dragging ass I'm irritable only with
the fear of the 9s that fear being alien
abductions before that reveal actually
happens though it's epic setup whether
it's moments where rker goes to his
quarters the camera stays on him he lays
down to go to sleep Jordy comes to his
quarters like hey you ready to work he's
like what are you talking about I just
went to bed and J's like it's those 700
hours dude lost an entire night and we
were there with him the entire time how
is that possible Warf getting sketched
out over a pair of scissors again with
the psychological horror like most of
these episodes are essentially
psychological thrillers but to me that's
scarier that's what makes something
scary and that's Peak scary Trek in that
scene where a few of them are in the Hol
deck like all right well let's start
with a table I remember a table and they
slowly start to form this thing that
looks like an operating table with the
ambient clicking sound of aliens
Spotlight on the table but the
background's really dark and jordy's
like I've been in this room before and
Riker is like we've all been here before
and this time around even data wasn't
impervious usually in episodes like this
it's like okay well what's data think
because he doesn't sleep he's not losing
time but he was losing time his internal
chronometer was off no one was safe
cherry on top is when Beverly Crusher
looks at ryker's hand and she's like
your arm has been severed and then
reattached it's off by like 0.6 microns
or something like that someone
surgically removes your arm and put it
back on probably when the audience was
watching you almost SLI and then I guess
a whole night just disappeared in this
case the Intriguing scientific Hook is
the power of the subconscious and its
ability to remember even if you
consciously don't this next episode man
I really wanted this episode but I also
wanted the episode called where Silence
has leas sorry nilum otherwise known as
creepy floating fetus face you got
bumped but you got bumped for frame of
mind that would be season 6 episode 21
because what is a list like this without
the Asylum episode Commander Riker
starring in a play we all love that
about track there's always those fun
recreational moments and this one takes
it it's like yeah but what if rker
starts losing his mind and going nuts
the play takes place in an asylum and
then rker is in the actual Asylum that
looks like the play and then he bounces
back and forth between the Enterprise
and the Asylum that looks like the play
one of the things I like about this
episode just in terms of film making is
that Tre famous line that rker delivers
in the play which is I may be surrounded
by insanity but I'm not insane seeing
him deliver that same line multiple
times throughout the episode as he is
going mad and seeing the inflection
change this episode did a miraculous
thing especially at being season 6 by
the time it aired we know that Riker's
first officer of the Starship Enterprise
and something else is going on but this
does plant the seed of Doubt of but what
if again with the psychological Thriller
episodes being among the best in Trek
when I made my five of my favorite
episodes of Star Trek the Next
Generation video frame of mind was on
the list but I really wanted cause and
effect on that list it broke my heart to
remove it so if we're talking creepiest
track episodes I'm including it here and
finishing off this list of five scary
Next Generation episode that would be
season 7 episode 19 Genesis which is
actually directed by Gates mcfaden who
plays Dr Beverly Crusher in the show
little tidbit the crew start acting a
bit strange you know something's up and
then Captain Bard and data returned to
the Enterprise via shuttlecraft the
Enterprise was is just kind of a drift
they get on the Enterprise and it's
clear this is the survival horror
episode of Next Generation the place
looks like a war zone it's completely
uncapped the lights are all flickering
and blinking data finds out that all
these dormant latent genes that we all
have after eons of evolution they're all
being reactivated among the crew and the
crew is De evolving for the life of me
with the concept of the crew is De
evolving I cannot reconcile oh and
Barkley became a spider maybe it's
because I'm not a biologist maybe it's
because entertainment writers are also
not biologists but I've done the mental
gymnastics and I come to the conclusion
of well you know entertainment but the
episode hits Peak alien when they're
being pursued by De evolved Warf that
looks like Predator well kind of you
don't really get a good look at him
maybe it's because of budget or makeup
it's best to keep him in the shadows but
it worked better you have enough to know
that Warf has become this really
aggressive pissed off apex predator
thing and that's all you need to know is
that warf's going to wipe him out
without knowing it cuz he's not
consciously Warf anymore that's actually
what freaked me out most is when Crusher
before before it all really goes down
we're still in the setup phase Dr
Crusher is like what are those sacks on
your cheek Warf open your mouth Warf
spits acid like Reptile from Mortal
Kombat point is this is the episode that
caused biologists to beat their heads
against the wall but in terms of tone is
a great survival horror episode of track
and it's one of my favorites I got to
give special props to Jonathan Franks
for flipping the bird on '90s Prime Time
television and not getting caught epic
move from a legend right there so that's
it that's my list of my top five
scariest or creepiest episodes of Star
Trek the Next Generation I know videos
like this comparatively don't get a lot
of views for my channel but hey I make
this for my fellow Trek fans out there
my fellow trekkies and gives you a
better look into my soul but seriously I
do appreciate you seeing this video on
your timeline you're like that's weird
I'm in watch it love you for that I know
there are episodes that you wanted to
see on this list that I don't have on
this list that's where comment sections
come in conspiracy almost made the list
that was on the short list too that's a
good one what are five of the creepiest
or otherwise scariest episodes of Star
Trek the Next Generation for you
whatever they are whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see
[Music]
more